the heart races deep breaths are hard to
find blood rushes through the body
that's fear anxiety scientifically we
tend to talk about fear as being a
response to immediate threats which is
right there in front first
anxiety is where there's the possibility
of danger but it's kind of looming on
the horizon and we're trying to work out
how probable is it how bad might it be
what can we do to avoid it
think of a lion right in front of you
that's an immediate threat looming in
the distance not as scary but still
something to be worried about
evolutionarily think about the hyper
vigilance that goes along with anxiety
as a very adaptive trait
because a long time ago the world was
super dangerous and humans needed to use
that hyper-vigilance as a way to evolve
it all starts here specifically in this
region amygdala is kind of flashing away
saying there's something dangerous we
need to react to and we release various
neurotransmitters and we need some of
those to have a good level of attention
to be able to be focused we'll see the
blood being shunted away from our
extremities and into the larger muscle
groups because if we needed to escape it
would be necessary those organs be
heavily involved the world has changed
and threats typically aren't as
clear-cut as a lion in front of you so
let's take a look at how our brains
respond to uncertain threats when we're
faced with potential danger uncertain
situations we feel better if we feel in
control we find it harder when
probabilities are changing rapidly after
what we rely upon are these kind of
simulation mechanisms where we try and
imagine if we were to engage in
different courses of action but that's
also after where biases can come in like
zero risk bias which might explain the
behavior of panic buying as humans we
have a strong desire for absolute
certainty so when we can't eliminate the
risks out of our control zero risk bias
may persuade us to completely eliminate
certain perceived risks regardless of
how irrational they may be
some panic by while others experience
optimism boys
we kind of had these very self
protective intrinsic desire to build the
world's a safe place and nothing bad
will happen to us when probabilities are
hard to estimate often those optimism
biases kick in no this is real this can
have consequences ok back to the brain
the amygdala going into overdrive is
necessary for a short-term threats but
can have negative consequences when
threats persist for the long term so we
can think of neurons in the brain as
being a bit like trees with branches and
those branches are called dendrites and
the prefrontal cortex which is involved
in reasoning and decision-making we
actually see those branches begin to
kind of whither and die back while it's
in the amygdala we see those branches
kind of grow into bulla and so that can
lead us to have stronger responses to
danger and for them to be less regulated
this deregulation can further lead to
anxiety and in some cases show a
correlation with depression and trauma
but these factors aren't permanent and
positive approaches to mental health can
help reduce them over time our ancestors
saw situations that challenged their
safety and well-being but overcame them
humans are adaptable we we are resilient
and we have that in us so even when
fearful and anxious we'll do what we've
always done
use our emotions to evolve
[Music]
[Music]
you